yeah we're sad to see him go John Legend
reacts to Adam Levine's sudden exit from
the voice we're very sad and he's been a
part of the show since it began 16
seasons and he's been so important to
the show even existing his replacement
Blake Shelton's girlfriend and former
coach Gwen Stefani Gwen is gonna be
great I think Blake is pretty happy
about it I'll continue to do trailer
talks he's got her oh sure
Chrissy also opened up about her new
kwibi app comedy show Chrissy's court
she's like quick little episodes but
it's gonna be so great working with mom
and and bringing her out to the world
because she's so funny obviously she's a
big part of my social media and stuff
but she's got a real job she's gonna be
judging people left and right
comedians people with petty claims know
which one she watches Judge Judy all day
so she knows what to do as a bailiff she
knows what to do she's well-versed in
the in the TV court tradition et spoke
with John and Chrissy at the Sesame
Street workshops 50th anniversary
benefit gala in New York City their
three-year-old daughter Luna is a big
fan so so happy that was going up a set
of lip sync battle
it airs tomorrow but she we had never
seen her that excited in our lives and
she was just so like you know what cuz
they have to stop down and change and
him to hide them from that part of it
but she was so we never been more
thrilled friends
I'm so excited maybe I can prove to Luna
that I'm a good singer
yeah she's skeptical still
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]